my name is David Madigan I'm the chair
of the statistics department here at
Columbia and I'm very pleased to
moderate this session I was going to
give you all the statistics lesson but I
think I'll desist and just go straight
to that straight to the panelists I was
going to give you a cautionary tale
about how how very difficult it is to do
insensible analysis of non design data
right so data come from design
experiments are one thing but the kind
of data that I think we're mostly
talking about here are fraught with
difficulties and risks in terms of
analyzing them and interpreting the
analysis but enough of that so the first
speaker in the in the panel is Jake
Carlson he's associate professor of
library science and a data services
specialist with the purdue university
libraries
thank you David and I really want to
thank everyone for inviting me to this
fabulous event I'm very pleased to be a
part of this as David mentioned I am a
librarian at Purdue University and I
want to take a moment before getting
into the meat of my presentation to sort
of talk a bit about data librarianship
at Purdue I want to then talk a bit
about life cycle models and I think
there's there's different types of life
cycle models that really are relevant to
the conversations that we're having here
and I want to take a brief minute to
introduce some different types of life
cycle models that I've observed then I
want to get into the the topic of the
panel in terms of focusing on the assure
describe and preserve aspects that we've
been tasked with talking about so when
no further delay / do we have a program
really that's designed to look at how
can librarians have an impact in this
new world of data how can we take the
the knowledge and skills & expertise
that we have that we've used for
centuries with with books and with
journals and apply this to this emerging
evolving world of data so do discuss at
librarians have in terms of organizing
and managing and disseminating and
preserving materials what to what extent
do they apply to this new world of data
and how can we engage in researchers to
help them as they explore this
particular area through through
increasing demands and increasing
pressures to do more with their data and
so in order to do this if we're to be
successful we really have to have an
understanding of the current situations
of researchers we have able to talk with
them and to figure out where they are
and what we can do to interact with them
how can we connect them with the
information resources and tools that
they need to do the work that they're
now expected to do with their data and
one of the things that we've done it /
do is to devise something called the
data curation profile toolkit this is an
interview protocol where librarians will
go and talk to researchers about the
work they do and there's there's sort of
three overarching themes that come out
of a completed profile we get
information about the individual data
set including information about its
lifecycle from the point of view of the
researcher and that's a really important
point that will emphasize a bit later on
on my presentation we get an
understanding of the current management
practices for the data that are being
done by the researcher how are they
managing and administer
working with the data and we get a sense
of the unmet needs that the researcher
have we we have a sense of what would
the research are like to do with the
data or it's required to do with the
data that they're not able to or don't
feel confident in at the moment so
capturing those unmet needs is all part
of a data creation profile as well both
the interview protocol and completed
data curation profiles are available
from our website which is data curation
profiles org so from the data curation
profile as I mentioned we generate an
individual life cycle as purported by
the researcher and so this is an example
of one of those from a particular
profile that I've developed and you can
see there's a fair amount of complexity
here and I know that you probably can't
read the actual text here but it's
comprised of a number of different
components it's comprised of the
datastage again as articulated by the
researcher so how does the researcher
interpret the stages that his or her
data moves through this information
about outputs what is the result of each
stage some information about file size
and the number of files information
about the formats and the different
formats as they switch through the data
life cycle and then some notes about the
particular stage in general to give a
description of the stage and what
happens and how the researcher
interprets that and I refer to this as
the individual data life cycle model
this is really hyper localized to a
particular data set into a particular
research lab the goal here really is to
capture that information from the
researcher and to use it to inform our
services and in interactions with that
researcher but there's also something
called what I've referred to as
organizational life cycle models so a
number of libraries and other
institutions are now offering their data
services they're kind of aggregating up
from the individual data life cycles
they see to come up with a life cycle
that's meant to cover a large number of
researchers or a large number of
disciplines this is an example from the
University of Virginia library's
scientific data Consulting Group they
came up with this and they've used this
as a means to develop their services and
to communicate those services with
people who may be interested in using
them and finally there's something that
I refer to as the community life cycle
model so communities of practice that
are out there such as data one such as
the life cycle model that we're using as
the basis for our conversations today
these are put out by communities to
share best practices
offer guidance to researchers and others
who are involved in working with data as
to what could or should be done with the
data so it is sort of a very high level
what what is what are the what are the
goals and aspirations that we have with
regards to the data and representing
that in a life cycle model fashion and I
think it behooves us at this point to
sort of stop and ask ourselves what is
the benefit of a life cycle model why
are we clustering ourselves around the
use of life cycle models how do they
help us well I think there's a couple of
different things that I can come up with
in your mileage may vary here about why
life cycle models can be of use it helps
define and explain some pretty complex
processes in a way that makes it easier
to understand and communicate so a
graphical representation of some pretty
complex stuff it helps to identify some
component important components roles
milestones other events that are needed
to do the kind of work that we do to
really understand and get at the nature
of the data and to make sense of it and
apply services towards it it
demonstrates connections between
relationships between component parts
and the whole with the knowledge that
what happens earlier in the life cycle
as a pretty important effect on the
later stages especially as we get
towards the curation and preservation
stages of things and it provides a
framework for us to develop services and
support and not only develop them and
sort of conceptualize what kind of
things we might offer but communicate
them both to ourselves internally so
that people involved in providing these
services have a shared understanding of
what it is we're trying to do as well as
to the audience's that we're trying to
communicate with in terms of offering
services but I also think it's important
for us to understand some of the
limitations of life cycle models and
doing this as well so I have the quote
here all models are wrong but some are
useful I do think lifecycle models are
very useful but I don't think we should
be blind to their potential limitations
and I think some of those limitations
are that they reflect the interest
perspectives and biases of their
agencies of reporting forth models of
best practice we're doing that from a
perspective of what we think best
practice is and that's important to
acknowledge the mask complexity so once
you get towards aggregating information
taken from individual life cycle models
you
you lose some of the complexity you lose
some of the distinction and detail of
those individual life cycle models that
researchers are going through they
overlook heterogeneity and diversity if
we're if we're putting forth the service
model that's meant to cover multiple
disciplines or multiple areas of study
you lose the distinction and differences
between those areas of study and they
often present research as orderly or
linear first this happens then this
happens then something else happens but
I think as we all know research is a
messy and complex process there may be
times you get to the analysis stage of
your research life cycle but realize
that you have an error in your data or
for some reason you have to go back and
start collecting data all over again so
it's not necessarily a neat and orderly
linear process and finally models depict
the ideal again going back to the notion
that we as service providers in this
area we want to see research done in
this way but research practice as it
goes on the ground may not in fact live
up to that ideal that we're putting out
there in our life cycle models and so
and with that in mind I'm going to take
a stab at trying to look at individual
life cycles through a community life
cycle perspective and this comes from
the folks that I've talked to you in the
interviews that I've done as a research
data specialist so this is sort of an
amalgamation of my collected impressions
of how research is actually being done
from the folks that I've talked with
first we start out with a plan and plan
may mean many different things to
different people often times it's
planning the research it's not
necessarily planning out the data the
data management plan requirement is
helping with that but I think as Gail
pointed out there's a whole range of
possibilities with data management plan
some folks really don't know how to
respond to this or see it as just
another document to fill out but other
folks have really taken to it and have
really sort of seeing the purpose and
the utility of it and have invested
themselves in that but there's wide
variation there in that particular stage
moving on to data collection data is
acquired or collected in some fashion
there's usually from the folks that I've
talked to some sort of stage where data
is processed it's it's filtered or
manipulated in some way to then prepare
it for analysis they this is where the
search question the data is analyzed to
try to answer that research question and
to generate value for that particular
researcher but all of this is done with
sort of the uber stage in mind with
publishing the paper that is driving the
data life cycle from the researchers
that I've talked to and oftentimes they
will include publication as a stage in
their life cycle when I asked them to
describe the life cycle of their data
set some of them will say well I do
publish my data in fact I publish them
in figures and tables in the article
itself and that constitutes data
publishing in my mind and so I think we
need to be aware that this is sort of a
very narrow path that that folks are
going down in the current environment
that they work in so with with reliance
on tour with discussion about ashore
assure is done I don't see this so it's
not described to me by researchers as a
separate and distinct stage it's not
really an event it's more of a process
and assurance goes through those initial
four stages of the data life cycle but
assurance is done in a very narrow
context it's assuring that the data can
move through this point to get to the
published paper that is the end goal in
assuring ones data in this particular
process and so things are done in terms
of quality control in communicating it
but it's done in the local lab
environment and usually it's not just
the fact that they're done in the stage
but assurance is better represented
maybe by the arrows between those stages
that the spaces in between those stages
where data is handed off or transformed
into different formats that's where
assurance we becomes critical for the
researchers in working with their data
and similarly with described described
it something that's also done by
researcher but it's done in a very
narrow context it's done to describe the
data so that others in the group can
understand and make use of it to
generate the published paper so
description oftentimes while it does
happen it may not happen in a written
format or in ways that can be captured
very easily it's often done during
one-on-one discussions between a
graduate student and his or her advisor
for example an advisor may have
questions and want to get a better sense
of what's going on but that happens in a
conversation and capturing a
conversation can be very difficult or it
may happen in communications via emails
that are sent across it's not
necessarily done in ways that are
associated
the data set and finally the preserve
aspect preservation is kind of a dotted
line out of publishing paper and that
it's a nice idea and it's something that
I think most resources I've talked to
really wish that I had but it's not
necessarily to take action to actually
doing it it's their preservation method
is kind of a benign neglect method and
as we all know that's really not an
effective preservation method but it's
not that folks aren't interested in this
they definitely are but they don't
necessarily see the benefit for them in
doing this if publishing in the paper is
the end goal it seems to be for most
folks but they also don't know how to do
it they have an idea of what a preserved
dataset might look like but getting from
there to where they are without the
knowledge and background and skills
they're not sure how to go about that
this is not their area of training and
so I'm going to take a moment to try and
recast that that data lies called model
is a slightly different fashion to sort
of talk about some of the issues that
we've got here I think as came up in in
one of the earlier presentations we have
sort of a problem with getting data to
the Eurasian stage to the point where we
can share it and use it outside of the
lab we have sort of an hourglass
situation in which active data
management takes place at the top of
that our of our glass and data curation
takes place beneath it and the choke
point is right here in the middle
because we're only getting what fifteen
percent was the the figure those
mentioned this morning that's a very
small amount from the actual work and
the actual day that's being generated in
these individual labs and so what I
think we need to do is look at our
current situation as kind of in the top
of the hour glass publishing the paper
as being the choke point with the dotted
line towards preserved which are the
kind of work that we want to do in
making the data more available this is
sort of a current situation we need to
pay more attention to how folks assure
and describe their data how do they
document that how do they describe their
data currently in their individual labs
and we need to be able to expand that
choke point not just to wait until the
data are published but to work with them
as much as we can earlier on a lifecycle
and not just about the data but about
how they describe or how they document
that data as well and to open up avenues
where they can share that information
with us earlier on in the life cycle
moral
I think we need to have a two-way
conversation the folks that I've talked
to are a keenly aware that they're not
doing the kind of job they want to do
with regards to documenting or
describing their data they're looking
for help they really want to know how to
do this in ways that not only benefit
what we're trying to do in sharing and
disseminating and preserving data but
can benefit them immediately further
upstream in the process where they can
get utility out of it immediately as
well as contribute to the larger field
and so we need to have better midway's
in more frequent ways of communicating
we definitely need tools we definitely
need resources but we need to find ways
to communicate those in ways that take
place during the research lifecycle
that's one of the things we're trying to
do it / do with deputizing librarians to
go out and had these conversations and
interactions with faculty thank you very
much the next speaker is Steven Morales
he's project director for the digital
preservation network and prior to this
work he was director of the Darden
solutions business school consortium at
the University of Virginia darden
graduate school of business all right my
name is Steve Morales I appreciate the
opportunity to be here with the digital
preservation Network you'll also hear it
referred to as DPN or deepen it's an
idea that's been percolating around for
a couple of years within the university
community and then really kicked into
high gear back in the spring of last
year there was a presentation made at
ARL and then again at the AAU presidents
meeting where the concept of having a
digital preservation Network an archive
a federated system of repositories to
control the data that on the long-term
basis could be controlled by the
university community themselves and not
dependent upon any one organization
anyone technology the whole goal is to
create a heterogeneous environment for
preservation that has no single point of
failure and it was after the AAU meeting
when the call was made I was not there
at the time and I pictured there was a
presentation at a podium and his fist
went down it says we have to do this and
20 university presidents said okay we're
in and then 30 and then 35 and 40 and
the presenters turned around and said
okay we got to do it now that's when I
came on board in July so I wasn't part
of the earlier conversations but I
kicked in and started in July after we
really were already up to 40 members had
put in the initial twenty thousand
dollars to fund the development of
deepen and that's how I will refer to it
that number is close it's over 50
universities at this point you can go to
the website it's DPN dot org that'll
give you some more background
information and most of the universities
I think that are represented here are
charter members within deepen and I
thank you very much for your
participation to get this get this
started Jim Neal is from Columbia is
actually the head of our succession
rights working group and has been a key
key leader thus far my first goal when I
got started with deepen in July was to
bring together the technology leads from
the five proposed repositories which
would make up this federated network of
repositories which is deepen I've just
finished having phone calls with all of
our 50 plus members giving them the
spring much the same presentation over
the course of 45 minutes so in the
course of the next 7 i'm going to give
you an update on what's been happening
so we have five repositories that are
currently proposed to be the initial
replicating nodes for deepen that is the
stanford digital repository chronopoulos
working with the san diego supercomputer
you've got tack the Texas Advanced
Computing Center working with the Texas
digital library hottie trust as well as
an up-and-coming organization called AP
trust those are the five repositories
who are at the table right now working
to build out it certainly won't be the
end of the repositories that we add for
the replicating side but those are the
ones that are at the table right now we
also have Duras space andrew woods from
dura space although they're not a
replica there although they're not a
repository their technologies are so
intertwined with the rest of our
membership that I thought it prudent to
have them part of the discussion so the
technology working group has been
meeting together weekly since July and a
conference call every Wednesday
afternoon which I'm going to miss today
but they've met face-to-face in Stanford
in Chicago and Washington DC and I and
their main task was to design the
initial architecture for deepen what is
it going to look like how is content
that is deposited into OneNote
going to then be replicated out to the
other nodes what's that framework look
like and they started off an exercise
where each repository created a strawman
architecture if they were in charge what
it would look like and then over the
course of successive weeks they worked
through each of those proposals and came
up with a final design for deepen which
they thinks is something we should go
forward with they've been testing that
design the last couple of months they've
been moving data around moving bits
around leading up to really this week
well there was a meeting in February the
very beginning of februari between the
deep and technology team down in Florida
and the deep in leadership group just to
make sure that we were still in
alignment now that they had created this
framework is thus are the services that
they proposed on the architecture that
they've designed actually what we
thought it was going to be and that
meeting went off spectacularly well
there was close alignment between the
initial vision for deepen and what the
technology working group is put together
and so tomorrow actually a newsletter is
going to the first deepen newsletter is
going to go out to the membership the
50-plus universities and their
technology teams and it's time to really
get into a period of feedback in
discussion is this the right
architecture how does your content go
from your repository in to deepen what
has been missed what needs to be added
what needs to be tweaked and by summer
time I expect that feedback process to
be sufficient to the point where we can
actually start doing use cases start
taking in data to start showing how the
process would work which will do for the
rest of 2013 and then deep and will be
open for accepting deposits from charter
members beginning in 2014 so again to
recap tomorrow or the next day is when
the first newsletter will go out it will
provide a not only an update on the
progress of the technology working group
but you will also be able to have access
to the technical working documents on a
wiki that is hosted by dorrough space
because I know many of you would like to
go deep into that I'm not gonna be able
to cover that today but go deep into
what's being proposed and I'm going to
err on the side of making a lot more
documentation available about deepen
than less so whatever you need to have
asked for it I will make sure it gets
provided that's the progress of the
technology working group the other
distinctive for deepen is that we are
actually going to be having succession
rights
in place for each of the deposits which
are made we don't want to have a lot of
content that's in a dark archive that 20
years from now we have no rights to do
anything with if the time comes when the
depositor is no longer interested in the
data or is no longer in existence we
need to have the rights in place that we
can bring that data back out to the
University back out to researchers back
out to the general public and so
succession rights will be key to making
that happen and as I mentioned before
Jim Neal from Columbia is leading a
succession rights working group to work
through these issues they've been
reaching out to other organizations and
I've asked them to provide a template to
templates by the end of spring which we
could then incorporate into agreements
with our depositors for deepen and I
would love to work off of the success of
other organizations so if any of you all
are part of a group that is dealt with
succession rights please get in touch
with us because we've been reaching out
to organizations and have found that
there's very little work been done in
this space with the XX exception of
icpsr which with data pass has really
we're going to looking at their their
documentation because they have actually
made great progress in this area that
working group in addition to gym is
comprised of Sandra enamel from OSU
Donna Furillo from Purdue Peter hurdle
at Cornell Kevin Smith at Duke and Prue
Adler from ARL those are the ones that
are working through those issues of
succession rights with the expectation
that they'll have some documents for us
to review at the end of the spring early
summer the leadership team right now
that is overseeing deepen has been
talking through governance issues
Michael McRobbie the president of
Indiana is reaching out to other
university presidents to see who would
be willing to sit on a board of
directors for deepen its going to very
much resemble the progress that was made
with internet too and there are a couple
of different paths that we could go as
far as governance in the future right
now we are technically a project within
internet too they provide all of our
financial services all of the money
that's been paid in to enter to deepen
is actually going to internet to their
providing audit fiduciary services we
could potentially stay within the
auspices of an organization such as
internet too or we could stand alone on
our own two feet as a non
profit organization with a board of
directors comprised of university
presidents CIOs and university
librarians and so the proposals of
governance will be going out to the
membership later this summer later in
the fall once we have some presidents
lined up who would potentially serve as
as on the board of directors currently
the leadership group consists of Paul
current hottie trust Brian shot lander
from San Diego Karan Wittenberg from UVA
Michael Keller from Stanford Paula
Kaufman with Illinois Winston tab johns
hopkins and wolpert MIT Jim Neal
Columbia Abby rumsey james hylton from
UVA Jon Wilkin Michigan Brad Englert UT
Austin and John Evans the founder of
c-span those are the ones that are
currently the ones i report to so while
our fiduciary responsibilities are held
by internet too there's actually nobody
at internet to that I report to I'm
reporting back to this leadership team
the final working group that is yet to
be convened but will be convened next
week is the business model working group
it's the one that I'm most keenly
interested in seeing what is the
sustainability model for long-term
preservation and it's going to take to
really two sides to that coin one is
what is the cost for preserving data for
a hundred years out I mean as far as
working with vendors to determine how
often are you gonna have to change your
mediums what is it what is the expense
going to be today to pay for long-term
preservation and maybe it's 20 years or
50 years there's gonna have to look at
what the long-term costs are I know
there's been some terrific research done
in this area especially I think
California digital library is has done
some excellent research on the long-term
costs think Syed over johns hopkins has
and so i'm going to be convening a team
of individuals focused on the cost side
of long-term preservation and then also
what are the revenue what are the
different sources of revenue for deepen
it'll certainly have a membership model
it will have some sort of deposit fees
associated with content that's going in
to deepen and we want to make sure that
we are not the first backup copy all
right we are we're not your Barracuda
network for your data but where were
your cat a straw
los recovery it's the content going into
deep in is going to be there it's going
to be preserved using different
technologies by different organizations
so we know that we'll have a copy of it
but we don't want you accessing it all
the time and so they need to be some
sort of governor in there to come with
withdrawal fees and deposit fees the
working group related to the business
model will work through these issues
bring it back to the membership make
sure that's something that's going to be
workable and then we'll move forward the
whole goal of deepen is together at
scale we have to be able to do this more
efficiently than we would all do it
individually and while we are focused on
preservation and the dark archive I see
deep in becoming as involved as we can
in helping facilitate the conversation
at the very beginning of the stack so
with with some of our momentum and some
of our funding we can help facilitate
conversations between researchers and
the librarian services the the local
preservation services that are going to
take place we would love to do that I've
talked to a number of funding agencies
I've been back and forth to DC almost
every week it seems like but meeting
with the archives and Smithsonian IMLS
and NSF i'll be going to NSF this
afternoon for a couple days working with
them but the funding agencies are
certainly interested in going to the
next step I don't know what it looks
like as it relates to creating the whole
business model around data and I have a
vision for creating a new economy around
data a new marketplace if you will where
data that is created actually has some
funding that's always associated with it
and that funding will be used by those
organizations providing access services
creation curation services and they'll
hopefully be a little bit left over for
deepen at the very end on the
preservation side and I don't know what
that looks like but I'm a bit of an
outsider to this community and it's just
clearly something that needs to be there
so that the access tier can be fully
funded and those that are providing
access services and local preservation
services can have a predictable funding
stream to pay for their services and in
talking to the funding agencies in
Washington they're very excited that the
universities have come together to fund
infrastructure and that's our first
stage we're going to build out long-term
preservation infrastructure very similar
to how internet to built out long-term
you know data pipes and now they're
providing nets let plus services deepen
is going to build that preservation
infrastructure and backbone and then
we'll be providing additional services
at some point in the future in
conclusion I'd like to say that while we
were really started by ARL institutions
and AAU institutions by no means is deep
in a closed community there's going to
be a place for whoever needs long-term
preservation as part of their strategy
and can plug in with deepen I am more
than welcome to bring you into the
membership of deepen things have been
really busy so if I haven't reached out
to you yet it's not because of neglect
or disinterest you were certainly
welcome to become part of deepen there's
forms on the website that you can fill
out either for membership or just to
receive updates newsletters and other
content as we go forward so there's two
different forms you could fill out on
DPN org and I would be happy to be
available to you individually as well to
answer any questions thank you very much
thank you Steve the third speakers is
Linda BB who's recently retired from a
position of senior director of psych
info at the American Psychological
Association she was co-chair of a
working group with the longest working
group name I have ever seen but it ends
with supplemental journal article
materials project business working group
that's the last half of it thank you we
didn't give ourselves that name i will
tell you
I too am one to thank the organizers and
the sponsors for inviting me this
terrific symposium I'm very happy to be
here today talking about this nice o in
n phase project a great many people
worked on this for what felt like a very
long time so we're glad to have it come
to fruition around 2000 when this swell
of supplemental materials began I don't
think any of us really anticipated the
burden it would become it was a brave
new world then technology allowed us to
add almost anything to supplement an
article and we did all of a sudden page
limits were not a concern for authors or
editors we I could add all kinds of text
and tables and figures authors weren't
paying for color figures when they went
up on the web and then there was all
that multimedia and all the gene
sequences structures 3d images
executables and so forth and there was
some data and what we had very shortly
was pretty much a mess there were no
standards and we all know how different
the cultures and practices are from one
discipline to another we ended up with
inconsistent identifiers or in
non-existent identifiers extraordinarily
poor metadata lack of discovery tools it
was a really haphazard whether you would
even realize that there was supplemental
data accompanying an article and so we
had what Sasha Schwartzman calls abuse
abuse of the repair reviewers who were
expected to wade through all of his
stuff and expect an abuse of readers who
really had no clear idea what it was
couple indicators of the problem in
august 2010 general of neuroscience
announced that it would no longer accept
supplemental material because of the
burden on their peer reviewers the
Journal of Clinical Investigation has
very carefully charted the growth in
supplemental materials
going from tooth out to percent of
articles when they began in 2002
ninety-five percent in 2011 and there
were other issues other journals have
followed suit cell had limited things in
2009 Sasha Schwartzman who was then at
IG you had had done a survey in late two
thousand nine and circulated a white
paper and we put together an ISO and
face a group of us a meeting on whether
this was really a problem at American
Psychological Association January 2010
and we formed this working group and you
will see that there was a wide breadth
of disciplines involved which was key
and trying to put together these
recommendations we actually had two
coordinated working groups there was a
business working group that Murray
McVeigh from Thomson Reuters co-chaired
with me and a Technical Working Group
that Dave Martinson who's sitting right
over here from ACS and Sasha Schwartzman
who's now at the optical society
co-chaired we formulated as a full group
practices that would help the scholarly
community develop more standardized
approaches we really wanted to lessen
the burden on everyone we wanted to
increase the potential for utility and
substance in the materials many of the
things we were finding on supplemental
materials are really not relevant or
useful my suspicion has always been the
editor said you have to cut that out of
the journal article and they threw it in
the supplemental materials and we want
to enhance the discoverability and then
the big thing was nobody had given too
much thought to how these things would
be preserved there are all kinds of
complications you really don't have a
full appreciation for how siloed our
disciplines are until you start trying
to look at citation practices even
things like placement of links it's all
over the place there's a real difference
in readers need for information you have
people who read for current awareness
you have experts who
want just snatches and then you want
people who really want to understand how
you went about doing this and then there
was we're all cleaning still to print
and yet the technology was changing so
rapidly when we first began talking in
the summer of 2010 when the work groups
got underway journals were almost all
text by the time we completed this in
2012 many journals were able to
incorporate same some things within the
journal article data was a key
discussion item at first because for
some people supplemental materials
that's what they meant they thought they
meant data but that's really not the
case we heard from both of our keynote
speakers this morning and our experience
is most of the supplemental data as
David said is audio-visual or in case of
Social Sciences mountains of text and
it's certainly supplement shows are not
suited the way we've structured them for
preservation I really like this
illustration that FG Schmidt and her
colleagues came up with you'll find it
on the STM website where she's layered
what we're talking about with data and
the publication data is just that little
tiny bit at the top of the pyramid and
what we ended up saying we would
consider in the supplemental materials
is that next piece other people are
dealing with all the other issues of
standards for collection submission
fixity and so forth we developed a
series of 12 guiding principles some of
them were just how we were going to work
but to that might be key to today is
that everything we came up with had to
be business model neutral and the issue
around the data so after two and a half
years of work we do have an official
nice o recommended practice and i'll
give you the URL and it is co-sponsored
by the National Information standards
organization and the National Federation
of advanced information systems the
approximately 35 page document is
divided into part a for business
practices and you'll see them there I
don't have time to go through them but
they really are selection editing
metadata a lot on discoverability and
then the Technical Working Group in Part
B have done things like provide a series
of minimal metadata and I believe there
was something like 18 optional elements
of metadata they've done a noun
normative DTD they've done a tag library
it's a very good piece of work when we
began to discuss supplemental material
we ended up dividing it into integral
and supplemental I mean additional and
you can imagine the 10 or 12 people on
the phone call when we started calling
supplemental material integral of what
an oxymoron but these are the things
that publishers are putting into
supplemental material they're putting
them outside the article because they
lack the technical ways of doing it and
we probably really believe this is a
transitory phase um I think that authors
got ahead of publishers and incapacity
actually and then additional is what you
really would think about about
supplemental it's relevant it's useful
but you don't need it to understand the
core article and what we really
envisioned is what um Emily Marcus the
editor of cell described as a layered
approach and in getting away from a
linear journal article that's been the
same for 300 years practically not quite
but last 60 or 70 anyway it would be
chunked and identified easily so that
the user can find what they need very
quickly when you go through this there
are four common themes persistency
linking is a big big deal and
bi-directional links and when we began
it was many repositories
could not do bi-directional limping
consistency publishers have been all
over the waterfront from article to
article from issue to issue from journal
the journal and we we're preaching
consistency discoverability not very
many and I services even tell you that
there are supplemental materials let
alone tell you what those supplemental
materials might be or link to them and
publishers have to make it easy for and
is to pick that up and then preservation
all the markup tagging distributed
repositories because publishers can't
always do this maybe shouldn't be doing
it maybe if there is an official
repository and that's where it belongs
for some disciplines there's not and we
got to figure that one out here are some
related sites the full document Sasha
had given a very very thorough
presentation at 2012 Council of science
editors on I presented at the XD
conference last fall and there were some
other very interesting presentations
there and then the article in an ISO
newsletter described what we were about
this document really is written
specifically for publishers encouraging
publishers to give very clear guidelines
to their authors their peer reviewers
their editors but we hope that it's
pertinent to all the parties in the
research cycle and we do hope it will
become these will become more useful
more persistent and not so difficult to
handle American Psychological
Association as soon as we came to the
end we took a really good hard look at
what we were doing then and what we
needed to do to be fully compliant and
our publications beware voted it all in
last november and dave was telling me
that he read the other day that there's
another journal who has said we use
these guidelines so i have lots of hope
thank you the respondent is robert downs
with senior digital archivist and acting
head of informatics and cyber
infrastructure R&D at the Center for
International Earth Science Information
Network here at Columbia
thank you David no have slides and thank
you to all the speakers as well as to
the organizers I think this is a great
session bringing together Jay Carlson
Linda BB and Stephen Morales Jake talked
about the different life cycle models
their strengths the limitations and gave
us an introduction to the data curation
profile toolkit that they use to
identify the needs of researchers for
each stage of the life cycle I thought
that it was insightful that he also
talked about how the the lifecycle
models demonstrate connections and the
relationships and the opportunities for
services as well that might be offered
to the research community to facilitate
the stewardship of their data also it
was interesting that he pointed out that
many of the researchers see the life
cycle going to the end point of
publishing the paper from a data
perspective we see that it's a little
bit short-sighted and often with the
data that's the beginning when you
publish the paper or near the beginning
I should say so I think that was an
interesting observation as well and that
the he sees the assurance is a process
in the descriptions and the preservation
really fitting in with that and how the
benefits of preservation are not always
obvious to those who are involved
especially those who or the researchers
I think that reminds me a little bit of
our discussions earlier this morning
where we're talking about how the
benefits really need to be apparent to
the researchers who are out there and
finally Jake mentioned that they we need
to work earlier with researchers during
the life cycle I thought that was really
a great observation
Steve Morales talked about the deep end
how they're organizing a federated
system of repositories and how they've
got over 50 universities already
involved and they've identified five
replicating nodes and the challenges as
well such as the challenges for
succession rights these the challenge
for sustainability models the will
facilitate long-term preservation and
how they really need to focus on the
costs as well as the potential revenues
in order to move forward in this and I
think some of the things that I saw very
valuable in this is that one of their
goals is to improve efficiency of data
stewardship and as well to improve the
funding opportunities so that they can
enable long-term our data access and
then finally Linda BB she talked to us
about easing the burden of the
supplemental materials and she observed
how the new technologies have given us
great affordances all these new
capabilities but at the same time
they've brought new challenges with them
and resulted in she mentioned lack of
standards some abuses extensive growth
as well as preservation which is just
hanging out there was a problem that
needs to be addressed she also offered
some guiding principles and earn
recommended practices both giving us a
business perspective as well as a
technical considerations and I thought
it was great that she and ended her talk
saying that she hopes it would be
pertinent to all parties in their
research life cycle which brings me to
another observation and that I think
when we hear about these different
systems the network's the tools that are
all being developed well we have to
remember that we've seen this before in
the development of mis systems for
example in the book development of data
systems as well we're all these
different groups are all developing
their own little silos if you will and
these are great that they're doing this
but I think we also need to think about
ways to integrate them so that in the
end the researchers will have choices
and the other parties in the process as
well will have choices and not just
choices that they have to make at the
beginning which repository am I going
with which network which tools but give
them choices so that they will have
flexibility throughout the entire to
data life cycle so if they change their
minds later they can say no I'm no
longer going with this network system or
repository or tools I'm going with this
other group now and perhaps later I'll
change my mind again thank you thanks
very much would any of the panelists
like to make a response or a comment at
this point before we open it up okay the
floor is open for questions comments I'd
like to take the things things I'm here
and I have the microphone and humble I
thought the life cycle models were
fascinating I mean I'm seeing their
thinking about that from the perspective
of a researcher and like you said
research is very messy and I was trying
very hard to fit what i do into that and
partly succeeding but not but not
totally and but in 1 1 way in particular
which is you know where you have the the
analyze one of those models you showed
and in the analysis itself generates
data yeah and actually one of the key
problems I presume I wasn't here this
morning I presume Victoria start and
talked with us this morning but I mean
the key barrier to reproducibility is
the lack of the data that go with the
analysis so in the field i work in
supposed with healthcare data and
there's essentially never enough data to
reproduce what somebody did and it's a
key
problem is how do you preserve that and
in particular if you you pick up an
article that's five years old or
whatever you know there is there's no
way to get back to you know the data
that existed at some point to describe
what that person did it seems to me a
key problem Leon Resnick RIT Oh Jake was
talking about different methods how to
control and destroy data quality and we
were talking about a number of different
indicators on the other hand we do have
a lot of data already available and
probably someone who come up is another
walk to share with us how long it takes
to double amount of daily David see
every year coffee probably but the
problem is that the data which is
available is very a camp owned by any
data quality indicator I'm sorry I don't
know if your mic is on I'm really having
trouble hearing you get your question
okay good okay so uh what I'm talking
about there are a lot of data quality
indicators available on the other hand
beta which is available is not a
component buying any data quality
indicator and that's a problem because
probably there are too many indicators
do you think that we have to start
thinking about creating some kind of an
integral indicator data quality which
will match together and because actually
from the point of you're a user user
wants to know how much trust I can have
in this particular date so you can't
answer this question okay um I think
what I was trying to convey wasn't so
much the the tools or the means by which
researchers used to assure their data
but the fact that that that process that
that task is more local
be focused and internally focused rather
than externally focused and one of the
things that I think we need to do with
regards to talking with our researchers
is to communicate a larger perspective
to them to open up that their data are
at that going to be used if they are
shared if they're men editor or choose
to put in the positive they are going to
be used by other people and to take that
into consideration when they choose the
methods of assurance so if there are
particular standards that are out there
for assuring or for documenting data
that are recognized as being trustworthy
that we need to connect them with those
those those standards in that community
to enable that sort of trust to take
place so I in the conversations that
I've had with data with researchers
using the dedication profile it's almost
sort of a stealth education process and
that I'll ask a question data discovery
in particular sort of comes up as one
that I've never really thought about how
others would would try to discover my DJ
it's not clear to me you know what I
would need to do to make that that
happened and I think that's that's also
the case with assurance it's not clear
to them what trust in their data would
mean outside of that local context my
crossbow from Rockefeller University
Press a question for Steven but whether
your network has gotten to the stage of
deciding what types of data you plan to
preserve it's a great question right now
the conversations within the replicating
nodes is that they would like to be
agnostic to what type of data that's
going into it so they're going to wrap
it up into a container that's going to
be put into the other replicating nodes
and so we're looking at text we're
looking at research traditional archive
data for libraries that they normally
used to be in their archives we're
looking at multimedia it's just it's not
going to be specific to any one kind of
data although certain disciplines are
further advanced in other words they're
dead their data is really ready to go
into long-term preservation and other
disciplines the data probably isn't
ready yet so I don't know if they
is your question or not yeah it takes
some thought to figure out exactly what
you're going to be able to host you
can't you just can't be completely
agnostic so you know there are types of
medical images that you know maybe a
file type that you can score store on a
disk but that file type in in that
format is useless to anybody so I think
it takes a bit more thought than just
saying you're agnostic well we're going
to start with the low-hanging fruit
first of all I mean it's for example
only one of the five replicating nodes
right now is can handle medical research
data I think chronopoulos is the only
one that's approved for medical data at
this point so we're obviously can't be
taking in medical data until there's
HIPAA compliance e across at least three
nodes and so what you'll mean this these
things will come out in the
conversations that are going to start up
really this week back and forth to find
out what are the right communities and
Winston tab from Johns Hopkins is
charged with starting aging a working
group to talk to the data communities to
find out which ones will be the first
ones coming in to deepen but your we're
not going to start with all the data
right now but our goal would be that as
we build out the infrastructure we would
not be excluding any one particular kind
of data for reasons besides technology
initially presumably there are issues of
scale as well an empty good I work with
some astronomers to generate you know
hundreds of terabytes at night I mean
that's we put some stress on the system
I presume quickly hi I'm Todd Heinz at
Princeton University I'm hidden behind
the columns I think for most of you
that's why uh well my my questions
actually very very similar the last one
but just also for Steven yeah because I
think with the the metadata with the
data description a couple of things with
people's experience one of my colleagues
describes it with a lot of tech people
they equate storage with access instead
of the metadata so you know having the
metadata in the description for access
and also that yeah the disciplines are
very very different and how you describe
the data social science what
they probably need from the description
in the metadata very different from
science data so yet it just seems like I
mean you kind of talked a little bit
about what your plans are but yeah if
you had a lot of of what you know your
committees and stuff to do that sort of
thing I think that's very very important
for us being able to access it and find
it in the future hi im sue moon sake
from University of Illinois I have a
kind of follow-up question myself so
from what I heard it seemed that you are
basically doing kind of beat level
preservation so basically what is
ingested in the system is given back to
the user but that I mean that kind of
beat level preservation has been
discussed in the last 15 years as not
really solving the problems with digital
preservation you know changes in
technology and these kind of things so
what are your plans in terms of
supporting you no access to the thing
that they have been ingested when
technology change I haven't heard that
one before I bet I'm just starting the
circuit it you're actually right bit
level preservation is what is the first
level of preservation services that are
going to be provide as they build out
the infrastructure moving up the stack
and providing additional services once
the infrastructure is in place is
certainly going to I know format
migrations is going to be one of the
first things that will be tackled within
this community to see how do you best go
about that there's been discussions on
how do you preserve the software that
was used to create that content now that
the software is no longer available and
so this deep in need to be taken care of
ma'am monitoring the versions and
storing and archiving the versions of
software being used and so these issues
again if we we could easily be stuck in
the mud if we try to tackle them all
right now and come up with a blueprint
for how it should work in all scenarios
before we actually get started and what
we're going to do instead is is actually
get the
Federation in place get the legal
agreements in place and then start
moving up the stack with different
services through collaboration with
people who have already tackled it in
different disciplines I mean some of
these issues have been around for like
you said decades it's been handled very
well in some disciplines so taking some
best practices from one discipline and
helping facilitate that to another
discipline I think could be a good
function of deepen going forward hi I'm
Gassman shortish from James Madison
University a question actually for you
Stephen we would mentioned you to have
this vision of creating a new
marketplace around data and relating to
the funding of data as access and we
heard earlier from of the keynotes
talking about taking freely available
data analyzing it repackaging and then
selling that data back to corporations
and I want to get a little bit more into
what you meant about creating this
marketplace around data because i think
this funding issue is very important to
many of us and i want to know if you
think the only option is taking other
people's freely available data and
repackaging it and selling it back to
other people is the only option apples
and oranges the two different uses of
the term there what I'm actually and
actually I have a question back out to
this community cuz i love the fact that
there are so many researchers in the
audience and so I'm going to ask a
question that I need the answer to as we
work through the business model for
deepen but what I'm referring to more is
that when data is is collected when it's
produced that there's some amount of
money that stays with that data for the
purposes of access preservation and
sharing going forward that's that's the
marketplace because if it data had some
money attached to it then people who are
providing access services people who are
providing the ability to share and see
that day would actually have some
funding available to them to manage
their operations they would have a
sustainable business model and for what
meant for me looking in the long term
what would make deep and successful is
if we had a very robust access to your
those disciplinary repositories
institutional repositories that are
providing services for access if that
was robust then we would have a strong
source of data coming into the dark
archive to the
reservation side we're not going to be
providing access services to the data
that's in deep and so once it goes into
deep and we're not going to be except in
a brightening event at some point where
we've been called upon to bring that
data forth we're not going to be the
source of access for content but my
question out to the researchers is what
would motivate you to set aside some of
your funding for your data to be
accessed in the future for sharing and
preservation once you're done with it
and if that answer is nothing is going
to motivate me to set aside some of my
funding for preservation and access I'd
like to hear that if something would
motivate you I would love to hear that
because I think it's a conversation that
needs to take place anyway I just
interject here I think what I would like
to see is some funding that comes in for
the project that is associated with the
long-term preservation stewardship and
access to the data and so if that money
was earmarked from the beginning for
that purpose then we could be assured
that it would be used for that purpose
so my name is Garrett Klimek so we run
this thing called nano hub where we have
240 thousand users a year I have a
comment regarding your marketplace right
you've got to make a marketplace you got
to make it working for providers and for
users the people that provide would like
to sell not pay right so you have to
create a marketplace in which users
ultimately willing to pay for access
that is how we trade products on the
market the providers get something not
pay for something so you have to develop
some some infrastructure where that is
actually a similar to an economy that
works quite well
bob chennai was the original respondent
but anyway I do have a questions partly
I think something Jake said talking
about the data life cycle from the
viewpoint of the individual researcher
but I'm just curious if you have
comments and thoughts about the
community data life cycle I mean we're
talking when we're talking at the level
of deep at a much higher level of in a
different ecology of users and funders
who might be the ones who would have to
answer your question Stephen so so how
do you see you know the individual model
scaling up to the the you know the
university or level or to the discipline
level or to the you know the whole
ecology of scientific data and data that
comes in from outside science as well as
but is used by science I mean there's a
lot of variations on the basic data life
cycle yeah absolutely and and it's not
that I'm trying to condemn community
life cycle or raise the individual one
is sort of the the answer because it's
not I mean they they serve very
different functions and while they're
all related they're distinct in their
functions and their purposes as it
should be I think what needs to happen
is more events like this and more
questions along the lines of what Steve
just asked of communicating with
researchers to get a sense of what what
information would inform a community
life cycle in a community you know based
service on the lines of what he's
describing so a means to connect people
and to involve them in the conversation
in ways that make sense that align with
with their interest so recognizing that
individuals do have distinct life cycle
models or distinct processes they follow
but being able to acknowledge that and
recognize that and fold that into a
larger community purpose
she's a researcher from where my
researcher hat that sort of resonates
with me that I think the mindset forgive
me forgive me if I'm incorrect but your
mindset is the research produces data
and then has an interest in preserving
that data yeah a lot of the certain
areas of research that I'm familiar with
I don't produce the data you know
there's there are central data data
gathered by other people by the
community so to speak and that if it's
not preserved it is I have serious
concerns about it but I don't produce it
mm-hmm but you still have a stake in its
presently you still need to be a part of
the conversation so yeah I think you
know individual recognizing that did in
fact are produced and we rely on those
producers as a means to to fulfill in to
contribute to all of this you're still a
stakeholder in that process even though
you're not a silly producer so so there
is a perfect business model right
there's people that provide and there's
people that use and there's a
marketplace you should be paying for
some of the data in some shape or form I
as a provider for example for non
electronic devices should have some
benefit from you getting getting usage
out of that it's the world is not free
right I mean it cost me a lot of money
to generate that data if you ask me to
provide more money to him to host that
data that's kind of backwards I mean but
that costs should be passed on
presumably to the people who are to the
users simply should we make sure we
built in nowise why should I pay first
no seriously there needs to be an
opportunity place mm-hmm there's
somebody back there
I'm sorry just to sort of continue the
direction this discussion has taken
there's been no direct no discussion in
the business model of the sponsors place
after all the investigator is unlikely
to fund any data preservation because
the investigator has no funds he's
spending that of the sponsor as a rule
so has the necessary agencies
foundations etc when approached as to
whether this is something they would
want in their budgets so at NIH at the
end of course NIH has a very diverse
portfolio of research and in for some
kinds of research the answer is yes I
was the director of the national
database for autism research for example
for a few years and in that model when
you get a grant to do human subject
autism research you are asked to put
money in to pay your people or yourself
to then send the data to end our in the
proper form and so forth we recognize
there's a cost to it and we say good
asked for the money in your grant and we
provided models for costing that and so
forth so the answer is sometimes yes
right we're also where we are yes we are
also correct correct so that that
particular end r is a federally owned
and operated repository but my point is
in terms of the cost of submitting the
data in all of that entails the answer
is yeah that's an example of where NIH
has been happy to support that with real
money
if I can directly answer your question
when I talked this morning about having
spoken to seven funding bodies that was
very much part of that discussion every
one of them said more or less yes and
Mike was one of the people I talked to
as well let me give you one small
example of where I know this is working
well as a repository archaeology data
service in UK small small but it has you
know usual funding problems one of their
one of their funding bodies is the
English trust who funds collection of
data if you will or they fund research
or they also will fund digging if
somebody is doing you know some kind of
digging up some area and they need to do
archaeological preservation on that site
before the digging or the building
continues or whatever so they fund that
research to collect the data they
require that every one of their funding
recipients go first to the archaeology
data service get a bid for how much data
they're going to collect how much is
going to cost to preserve it and then
that gets baked into the contract itself
for the funding that they get one of the
models that does at least in some areas
does work and so yeah I heard soundly
again and again oh that's an interesting
model yes we like that and you're
hearing I think more and more of the
putting it into the funding grant of the
X percent that will kick care of the
data forever i'm not sure that covers
all the costs that's what i was trying
to say this morning but that model is
certainly in play I have one more
example that is more analogy in any NSF
proposal you write these days about a
quarter or a third of the space you
ought to be using on education and
outreach you create a product that you
normally would never create if it
weren't a requirement or you're a gifted
person that just wants to do this kind
of stuff and it's only credible if you
actually put real resources and not
right so if we actually write our
grounds that say I really need to and we
buy into that I need to deposit data
here and I want to participate and I can
get it funded it most agencies will
probably pay for it and it shows that
the p.i is actually serious about it so
I'm kind of talking cheek about why
should I pay for it but
right but ultimately you need to create
a marketplace that pays for it by itself
but once it start once it before it gets
there it costs money from all kinds of
sources but it's the p is that decide
they want to do it if you go there and
twist arms and don't provide value from
it it's just twisting arms it's not
going to happen but one missing piece is
the reviewers have to actually look at
that material the panel and the staff
have to take it seriously and in some
sense there have to be community
standards of what is reasonable for that
and I think that's one of the gaps that
certainly inhibits the standard process
there are panels that take that pretty
serious if you say my alter ego gram is
I'm going to travel to knees and friends
and hold a little workshop you're going
to get killed right or if you say I'm
going to run a big website and you don't
put any money into it you're going to
get killed I mean the panel's I've been
on they see it they look at it and
there's I'm sure there's others that
don't give her but I do want to address
the marketplace idea deep in itself is
actually behind the marketplace that
you're referring to in a sense of the
accessed here with hundreds of thousands
of users that are coming in and asking
for data that's not going to be deepens
role is providing access to content well
we would be behind that access to your
and if you're providing you you need to
preserve your data so how are you going
to preserve your data okay you're going
to have a backup copy but what is your
preservation plan and is can deepen be a
part of that preservation plan for the
long-term preservation of that content
and so we would charge you for your
deposit into deep and that's our value
that we're adding is instead of you
building out a large infrastructure with
multiple copies and multiple
environments that's where we would come
in we have to provide value to that
access to your in order for us to have a
business model but the one that you're
speaking to where people are actually
coming in retrieving data that
absolutely needs to be developed that I
wouldn't fall into ours
the true market I just want to preserve
all the data by a hard drive our deposit
sure yeah so I want to make a couple of
points there are there are a lot of
models competing in this area and I
don't think we know really yet where to
go just to add another model that works
very successfully the National Institute
for justice when it Awards grants
withholds from the p.i the last ten
percent of the grant until the data is
archived so so we get since we maintain
their archive we get very high
compliance from them but that raises a
that raises another there I think there
are a couple of issues they're here one
is that but if we're asking the POS to
put this money for the archiving into
their grants first of all they're doing
that before they even started the
project and we get requests for
estimates all the time and it's very
hard for us to know what's going to come
out at the end in particular we find
that one of our the biggest things that
drives up the cost is whether the P I
will answer questions that we send them
because we have we have you know data
sets where we get the data and it takes
us two years to get them to answer it
quite you know a few emails so we can
release it and we have no control over
that and that the if you think about
this in terms of preservation the
fundamental problem here is is that
we're trying to use a short-term funding
mechanism for a long-term purpose and
assuring that you have long-term
preservation it you know is very
difficult I I don't think it's
impossible I think it but we need we
what we might need is for the funding
agencies to actually be willing to put
put that money in in a way that that it
is for the future or perhaps for the
past in a certain sense
this the second big issue that hasn't
really been been brought up very much
but is very related to cost is the
question of of what are we actually
going to preserve because the policies
that most you know NSF and NIH have
tended to to put out our that we should
preserve everything and as a starting
point I think that that's not so bad
because I'm trying to get people to to
to think about preserving things in
sharing things but in the long run not
everything has to be preserved and not
everything has to be preserved forever
we did a survey on the Michigan campus
and there are differences between
disciplines there are certain
disciplines that think in five years our
instrumentation will be so much better
that anything's collected today is not
going to be worth it even in and you
know if we tried to preserve and curate
to the highest level everything that
came out we would simply bankrupt the
system so one of the things that we have
to think about and i must say that I've
you know I've thought of the question
but not the answer is is how do we
choose what we invest our our limited
resources in in in terms of curation and
preservation for the long-term save
saving and keeping all data doesn't make
sense so that's not our policy our
policy and in fact that what i was
talking this morning about using peer
review to help us go through these
things it specifically is targeted to
take the community norms into account
yeah
probably follow on to some of those but
in terms of in terms of the demand and
actual usage of this data may be
something you could speak to some of the
better examples of maybe it's categories
of use in terms of replication of a
certain study or or using the data for a
new study but I mean what kind of
outrage or was there any reaction when
the journal no longer started accepting
or stopped accepting the supplemental
materials and I feel like a lot of these
uses of the data probably can drive the
prioritization of what needs to be
captured so are there stories like that
yet I don't really think so there was a
big buzz when the journal stopped but
the truth is I think most of their data
are already being deposited in other
repositories um and and now it's just
sort of a historical no so my question
is kind of in between the idea of a
business model and the kind of services
that you provide so I mean given the
fact that we there are cloud storage out
there you know I'm just thinking about
Amazon s3 this kind of already used in
the academic community kind of cloud
storage with replication and all these
kind of things what would be the benefit
of people coming to you instead of using
this kind of services that are already
are out there and have well established
infrastructure and and so on and given
the fact that this idea was proposed and
sixty libraries came together instantly
and said we need to do this with full
knowledge of what Amazon's providing
there's probably a lot of hands in here
that could talk to these specific needs
I don't know if we need to go down that
tangent right now but we're certainly
not competing against somebody in the
realm of Amazon three this is a
community people the university
community wants to own their own
solution they want to control how this
works for the long term as part of their
core mission of preserving the academic
record so it's not really just about who
can provide
I'd the best bit level preservation at
the best price that's really not where
we're working and there are a couple of
hands that probably answered me yeah I
mrs. Bennett Blumenthal i'm here at
columbia university and run a data
library but that i think that the
precise issue is that the cloud the
cloud the cloud is not about digital
preservation it's actually precisely the
opposite of that it's only interested in
things at the moment it's a
computational service they'll keep the
data as long as you pay them i mean they
throw it away immediately when you stop
which is not digital preservation in any
sense this is rob cordell on oklahoma
university libraries in fact in the
conversations were having with doris
space which is one of the agencies
working with DPN we are in fact looking
at how some commercial service providers
might integrate with a long-term digital
repository so for example maybe not
amazon s3 but amazon glacier which is
actually a service that is being offered
by amazon could be a solution the key
thing however is you need to have a
layer on top of that which provides some
level of packaging and metadata and the
key aspect of DPN is that it doesn't
rely on any one piece of technology and
ain't no one particular vendor in terms
of how you store it that's a very active
research conversation it's something
that we're talking about with with deep
and right now and the final note is when
you use a commercial cloud provider you
have variable costs in the case of
Amazon you have variable network costs
and one of the things that we strive for
in universities is at least in library
world is some level of stability in
terms of budgeting the costs of storage
and preservation and you have to factor
in not just the storage costs but then
but the variable network costs so those
are just some of the things that are
going on it's not that cloud is not part
of the solution it may be part of the
solution it may be part of the solution
for some communities and not other
communities and that all has to be
factored into the to the to the
conversation
we're saying is is that amazon services
are not precluded from it as well as
other commercial providers but that
there has to be a layer above that that
provides for both an entrance strategy
and an exit strategy for the
contributing notes for DPN and
replicating notes hi i'm mark from fig
share and i just wanted to say that we
do exactly that we have a layer on top
of amazon services and we use s3 for the
access for now because if we're talking
about access but i agree if you're
talking about archiving then it's a
completely different conversation and we
do use glacier for our backups but if
you're talking about dark archives then
it's probably not cost effective if you
talk about access now then it is a good
solution just a couple minutes left any
last questions yuria panelists like make
any comments well it motivated
researcher to set aside funding that's
about 20 minutes ago I'd like to add at
the end if I could to come back to a
comment that was made earlier by gerhard
that there are models other than pay
upfront that can get money back into the
repository there are uses for data
commercial uses for data they're being
done today especially in the genomics
area as i was mentioning and they are
what they're doing is they're getting a
free ride because they take the data
that's freely available they munge it
around they create products and they
sell those products and they don't pay a
license fee back to the repository that
it got the data from and that to me is a
lost opportunity that could fund from
the other end eh it's may be anathema to
us and I know I'm putting my head on the
block here being a commercial
representative but I mean even if we did
that why shouldn't we pay a license fee
for the data that's in an academic
research repository if we're going to
turn it into commercial use because that
can help as another model that can help
fund some of the repositories
last question here um so it seems to me
this is all tied to the whole Open
Access Initiative the carrot at the end
of this stick that we find i work at
Harvard Business School its tenure so if
we're working with junior faculty who
are working toward tenure they will
comply with anything you want them to
comply if you're dealing with senior
faculty who are out there consulting and
like there is no compulsion I mean that
no they just don't need to comply with
anything so it seems to me actually I
was having a discussion with Linda about
EBSCO and and the way they had this
brilliant strategy to get a market in
the k-12 schools and they built this
entire world of researchers who come to
universities and now all they want is
obscure post because that's what they
were exposed to and it's like Google so
if the cat if we can the carrot for the
faculty who need to have tenure working
with getting an advisory board of
university presidents to understand this
issue working with people at the highest
level of the organization to promote
this issue and to begin to make it
standard and requirement for ten year
just like we would really like to have
open access d is it seems like that's
where we need to start the carrot is
tenure for faculty all right I've done
take the palace for a very stimulating
discussion
you